do you remember how this whole thing
started like the whole sim movement
thing started or was it something like
it was just like an internet phenomenon
if anything i
i don't know i don't want to speculate
too much but maybe at some point
uh
people saw like girls doing really well
yeah yeah yeah clock that they're
viewers or guys or that they
got a certain type of energy i don't
know why maybe for some people that like
it
makes them feel jealous potentially
right right or to them it just doesn't
really make sense
i don't even want to try to understand
it or you know whatever because i think
yeah definitely i think there was like a
a very
you know a very long period where it was
it was a very gradual rise of like oh
girls play games and stream too guys
it's like whoa what the [ __ ] you know so
it's like i think it's from there that's
when it started to kind of this movement
of like just people who clearly were
never in the right mindset to begin with
who was suddenly like wow
look at all these men conforming to
these female streamers what just because
they're good at league now they're
suddenly they're your wife it's like no
they're just they're just entertaining
people and they just want to like watch
their favorite stream or regardless of
the gen does like maybe the other thing
is um
i think it is really really hard to
break through
on twitch yeah yeah absolutely it's such
a saturated platform yeah three four
years ago when it wasn't a saturated it
was still hard then yeah and it's
especially hard when you're the 100
000th guy to stream yeah but when you're
a girl because you're like more rare or
more of a minority on twitch
sometimes you can have an easier uh
start only start not middle yeah
but sometimes you can have an easier
time gaining initial traction again
because you stick out in comparison to
all the other
smaller or newer streamers and i think
when they see this like advantage in a
sense
i can understand people being upset at
that like
no i don't have the ability to do that
right and then they twist it into
like i guess viewing that person's
gender negatively or being like oh it's
just because people are simping for them
like they turned
i guess this situation
into just calling other people yeah yeah
to discredit whatever viewership or
success that person yeah i'd say you're
in the category of just like just a
normal streamer who is a girl right yeah
and i think the
the what the reason why it's a really
[ __ ] annoying conversation to have
about all of this stuff is because
there is a some people who stream on
twitch who happen to be women who
definitely push the [ __ ] envelope
like just just take the piss with what
like should be allowed yeah
is it is it
is it frustrating when you feel that
like you're trying to kind of sh like
push like hey we can do this stuff and
then you just flip over to the other
category and this woman that's naked
literally slobbering on like an ear like
how do you
how do you deal with that okay i
actually had a freaking epiphany
regarding this okay right
years ago
mainly when as i said like there was all
this variety yeah virality around like
this girl shows cleavage and games like
she's
smexual
no i kid you not but back then like
those were almost the only girls that
could have like 2k plus viewers aside
from maybe like khafu during her pro
like casey tron was that what it was
yeah she wasn't mean but like yeah that
was crazy yeah yeah she's so funny yeah
yeah um so
that really those kind of were the top
female structures
at a very initial point on twitch and at
that time
i there was like some frustration i
think for a lot of female streamers
because they're like people come into
our chats and they either expect this or
you know they label all female streamers
as this one thing right
even in college when i told people that
i streamed they're like you're a cam
girl
no no i'm on a webcam but like that
doesn't necessarily mean i'm a kid
yeah
even my roommates are like you do yeah
yeah like video games
so i i turn on the computer i stream
online to thousands of viewers and they
give me money sometimes
why do i think i'm a cam girl i don't
know that's like when you try and
explain your streaming career to like
your grandma you know it's like it's
like the most like rudimentary like
youtube doesn't know what i can go yes
you shouldn't know
well yeah so initially there were some
frustrations where it's like you know i
feel like
right yeah but i remember um someone
told me once they were like
you shouldn't be upset at the female
streamers who are doing that you should
be upset at the guys who are expecting
you to do the same thing just because
they saw someone else do it or for guys
who are having one assumption about an
entire gender based off of one person
that they saw yeah and i was like
true
third eye opens
because it is difficult not to be
frustrated when you feel like there's a
negative stereotype yeah and not be
upset at the people perpetuating that
yeah but also if anything i'd be more
annoyed at like the people click baiting
them um and like trying to
sensationalize it like if homegirl wants
to make her money go make your money
yeah yeah especially nowadays like you
don't have to be mad at all because it's
it's been made much more clear like
streamers can come in all sorts of types
and right yeah yeah and that's a really
interesting point because i think part
of the problem was that talking about
the problem just became as profitable as
like the pro problem itself yeah like
that which made it seem like a bigger
problem than it is yeah yeah that's
right yeah like the the rise of
especially commentary and drama
youtubers within like the past five
years just like kind of coincided with
this kind of witch hunt
triggering my pts i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
are you kidding me yeah
yeah that's like a similar thought to i
think we spoke about this before on the
podcast it's like um
you know how uh sometimes people are
like you know uh parents should treat uh
should teach women how to like avoid
[ __ ] creepy [ __ ] weird dudes and
it's like and i think someone uh
commented on long lines of like uh it
was like uh no you should
parents should teach their uh male kids
to not be [ __ ] freaks yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's which is true yeah yeah you
like solve the issue from the most
fundamental place and not yeah all the
way up at the top yeah i think
unfortunately it's just easier to like
pick on like one public target rather
than just a lot of faceless masses
because then it's just like well
society right
there's not there's nothing we can do
about it yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah you were so right there was like a
period of time where it was especially
profitable to pick on people or make
videos about them or speak negatively on
on them yeah regardless of what platform
they were on youtube twitch tick tock
yeah
every week
yeah yeah taking people apart yeah yeah
and for a long time like i felt really
bad about myself because i was like i'm
that problematic man
no you were too successful your name was
worth a lot and it would get clicked
that's certainly complimentary it's
right
as one human being yeah knowing all
these human beings are talking about is
weird
yeah and it's hard
um i i guess almost like math or like
logically it's hard not to think like oh
maybe i am the problem right and not to
say that i'm a perfect person but in
hindsight it just had a lot to do with
the position that i was in like if
if you would put any other person and
name on the channel that i was on it
would be their names in those titles
instead exactly exactly and the thing is
because because of like the problem that
your name was just so i guess like
recognizable
and clickable like you do like one thing
and i swear like people were just making
[ __ ] nine part series on this like
one
that was like barely an issue to begin
with yeah and it was just like and
people clicked on it and it was
unfortunate at the time i don't know if
it still was prevalent nowadays but
there was definitely a time i think it's
i don't think it's as prevalent nowadays
because i think now there's a lot of
commentary channels who have now opted
towards the route of like we're not
gonna necessarily give our opinions on
this thing but we're just going to state
the facts and what we know and it's up
to you to decide
what you want to take out of it yeah but
at the same time i think what a lot of
those channels don't understand is that
their audiences for the most part aren't
as intelligent enough to just make up
their own opinions you know usually they
go to those videos because they want
them they want the team you know they
want the drama they want an opinion to
get behind whatever you're covering yeah
whose sides are you showing how much how
deep are you really looking exactly are
you showing the first report you saw on
dixterra with that shitty [ __ ]
articles yeah yeah yeah
that's been oh yeah yeah i was gonna ask
yeah so
i've recently started getting these i
don't know if this means that i'm doing
well i think that means i'm doing well
yeah i think so it's like it'll be like
twitch star sea dog [ __ ] took iron
masks to a park on stream and it was
wholesome and then there'll be another
one it's like
twitch star [ __ ] exceed i love the word
twitch star so i call myself uh
twitch star c dog falls a jump king and
it's like that's not news they do this
for everything really every they'll be
like xqc had an opinion here it is yeah
no but
is
sometimes
just me man like they write that crazy
[ __ ] about them
okay what are they right what do they
write okay i have this kind of joke that
i've made i think three times which is i
have these two cats that i love so much
um and i care a lot like i'm so invested
in my cat are you chilling okay yeah
yeah yeah
um but sometimes i you know my mind goes
so far i'm like
i think my cat should roam free
like
high quality tuna three times a day
every cat owner knows the cat owns you
yeah you do yeah yeah yeah
the cat does what it wants yeah you you
are the cat servant yeah it's living a
good place are very good at surviving on
their own it will it will it will be
fine but like you know my mind goes this
far and i'm like you know it's my dream
i want to live on a farm but it's in
clothes an enclosed farm so it can roam
free but i never have to worry about it
like going too far yeah okay so how does
this leave free range
right okay
so
one day i was making this joke blah blah
blah blah blah just like i did to you
guys right what does a dexerto dexter
article say it says
pokemane breaks down
in the middle of valerie like what
what's wrong she's like i read an
article
i don't mind the articles it's just like
what the [ __ ] what are these what are
these titles i don't know it's just
interesting how they choose to
sensationalize them but it's really made
me realize like whether it's youtube
clickbait or random articles online
people will believe anything they can
read yeah
it's true yeah unfortunately it's gone
to the point where you're just bombarded
with so much [ __ ] that you read like one
headline and you're like yeah okay i
guess that happened you know
and it's just a slow news day
yeah
especially now with like [ __ ] tweet
longers being entire dissertations
you're like i can't read through all
this just like sometimes all of a sudden
i'm not literate yeah
like i feel i feel bad i feel bad but
sometimes i'm just like just tell me how
to think it's right like i i don't have
the time to get it
i think it's both like human nature it's
sometimes just easier to agree with
someone when they make sense and it
feels good you're like yeah that's true
when they're passionate about it you're
like you have energy for this
i have energy to agree which is out here
yeah but the and also i think we're so
as you said like overwhelmed with
information and different titles and
comments and this and that and that it's
hard to tell what is like true or not
especially when someone is like
confident and it sounds like it makes
sense like
but that's been very difficult in my
position and it sometimes just feels
like i have to go so out of my way to
correct
all the random things other people are
saying yeah that's exhausting
those people are gonna believe whatever
they want right if you
if they see this article they're gonna
believe it and even if the article
didn't exist they're gonna make up [ __ ]
in their head and why they don't like
you but you know what's sad i actually
kind of disagree i think there is like
let's say
20 yeah i think there's like a group of
people yeah they will believe anything
negative about you and you cannot
convince them
out of it because they didn't convince
themselves into it they wanted to hate
you from this year yeah yeah but i think
there is like
quite a
like quite a big group of people
that might just have gotten the wrong
impression or believed something is that
big i don't think it's that big i i i
think that like it's it's hard to truly
go insane trying to correct all the
false [ __ ] about you online and maybe
it's not big maybe it's not a big deal
but like just trying to correct all the
stuff all the time it's like why do i
give a [ __ ] about this let me just play
video games i really don't [ __ ] care
i think um like it depends for example
like nowadays it's not something that
bothers me as much right right but
during a very specific like year or two
of my career for sure that felt like the
majority of my life like
and i especially guys i didn't kick my
cat
okay
i noticed because like again months or
like a year or two later i had a lot of
people like an influx of people that i
would see everywhere just saying like oh
i'm sorry like i had a really bad
impression of you because of xyz but now
i realize you're normal yeah yeah
yeah a lot of those kind of comments
so cause you get
i think what can happen is as well and
it's it's nothing like it's not that bad
but
you you see all this stuff about you
online and people are saying these
things and you get frustrated about it
and then
the one thing that i've had to like try
and dial back personally as well i was
like try not to give too much
frustration
uh often stream or publicly because in
it
some people see that and they're just
like i just don't like this energy yeah
they don't like it and that freaks them
out yeah and then they'll get a bad
impression yeah right it's not even
about what you say it's about how you
say oh yeah yeah that's what makes it
believable or not essentially no
definitely yeah well because the way i
see about it is that every creator gets
like they get like one dunk they
everyone's allowed one dunk where they
could be like yo this guy's talking
[ __ ]
and the guy's a clown you're like you're
you're still people will be like well he
he's kind of like getting a bit too
involved in this right he's carrying a
bit too much he's a bit too defensive
right yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's
something you're too involved in drama
people just think you're sauce yeah yeah
even if you're like what are you hiding
yeah yeah yeah so desperate it's just i
don't know yeah